did you realize that virtually all the
cellular estrogen and men and women come
from testosterone and so there's a
certain enzyme called aromatase that
converts testosterone to
estrogen and if this enzyme is triggered
too much you can actually end up
estrogen dominant so if you're a woman
you could be at risk for breast cancer
but if you're a man you can start
developing breast tissue so one of the
biggest things that increases this
enzyme
plastics so if you haven't seen my video
on plastics check it out on my website
right now an average person consumes
about five grams of plastic every single
week that's the size of a credit card